I think about this often when I got
started in the business I was a writer
and standout live for my and I'll never
forget the day that they said that comic
Laughlin's here he's gonna host this
week that's exciting
right and Jim Downey the head writer
said hey Conan why don't you come grab
lunch with comic Lockland and I and I
was just a kid and that was the biggest
thrill you could not have been nicer
okay we're really funny you were nice to
me you put up with me I think I I was
this height and I weighed about 150
pounds and I was just I was like a stick
with an orange wig on the top but you
were very nice I mean I always
appreciated you I had such a great time
and that was in 94 the first Twin Peaks
that's right and and everyone was just
so nice and the writing was
extraordinary they did that great Twin
Peaks sketch and I think that think I'm
in that they put me yeah Chris Farley in
that sketch they said they were always
on that show saying we need a cop and
you know they're like you're Irish put a
hat on him and a new bird they literally
just before the show put a hat on me and
said you hold on to Chris Farley he's
the bad guy and so and of course all my
parents were calling all I did was hold
on to Chris Farley's arm in that scene
you can look it up on YouTube and I got
all these calls for my parents you were
incredible everyone was looking at you
oh I'm doing nothing in that scene that
was a great scene and Christmas that was
Chris Farley's first I was right that
was his first just for show
you